AND SO, AT 9:00 P.M. EASTERN,
SEAN HANNITY TAKES OVER.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, TALKER,
THANK YOU, AND WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
TONIGHT, DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN IN
CHARGE OF CONGRESS, THE
WHITE HOUSE, FOR JUST 16 DAYS
AND AS PREDICTED, THEIR
VINDICTIVE RADICAL EXTREME
AGENDA IS NOW TAKING CENTER
STAGE IN THAT SWAMP.
AS WE SPEAK, THE BITE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION NOW IS QUICKLY
IMPLEMENT JANE AOC’S INSANE
GREEN NEW DEAL AGENDA DESTROYING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF HIGH
PAYING JOBS IN THE PROCESS ALL
WITH THE STROKE OF A PEN SIGNING
NOW 47 EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND
ACTIONS, WHICH IS OVER TWO AND A
HALF TIMES MORE THAN OBAMA,
BUSH, AND CLINTON COMBINED.
NOW, MEANWHILE, NEXT WEEK THE
U.S. SENATE IS SET TO HOLD
ANOTHER POINTLESS VICIOUS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IMPEACHMENT
SHIFTSCHIFF SHOW.
THE OUTCOME IS PREDETERMINED TO
SMEAR TRUMP ONE LAST TIME.
IN THE HOUSE, DEMOCRATS ARE
WAGING A CAMPAIGN AGAINST
REPUBLICAN FRESHMAN LAWMAKER WHO
HAS BEEN ON THE JOB FOR ONE
MONTH AND ONE DAY.
JOE, BY THE WAY, IF YOU ARE
STILL AWAKE, YOU ARE STILL WITH
US NOW, YOU ARE LEADING A
COUNTRY WITH GREAT UNITY.
GOT TO GIVE YOU AN APPLAUSE FOR
THAT.
AND TONIGHT DURING A HOUSE WIDE
VOTE, CONGRESSWOMAN, MARGIE
COVERMARJORIEWAS STRIPPED OF ALL
BECAUSE OF THE THINGS THAT SHE
SAID BEFORE GETTING ELECTED.
HOUSE DEMOCRATS WENT AHEAD WITH
THEIR PUNITIVE MEASURES EVEN
THOUGH CONGRESSWOMAN TAYLOR
GREEN HAS NOW DISAGREED ABOUT
HER PREVIOUS BELIEFS AND CONDUCT
DURING AN UNSCRIPTED SPEECH ON
THE HOUSE FLOOR TODAY.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN I STARTED FINDING THIS
INFORMATION, THINGS THAT WERE
NOT TRUE IN THESE POSTS, I
STOPPED BELIEVING IT.
AND I WANT TO TELL YOU ANY
SOURCE AND I SAY THIS TO
EVERYONE, ANY SOURCE OF
INFORMATION THAT IS A MIX OF
TRUTH AND A MIX OF LIES IS
DANGEROUS.
YOU SEE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS ARE
ABSOLUTELY REAL.
AND EVERY CHILD THAT HAS LOST
THOSE FAMILIES MOURN IT.
I ALSO WANT TO TELL YOU THAT
9/11 ABSOLUTELY HAPPENED.
I BELIEVE THAT DAY CRYING ALL
DAY LONG WATCHING IT ON THE
NEWS.
ADDED IS A TRAGEDY FOR ANYONE TO
SAY IT DIDN’T HAPPEN.
AND SO, THAT, I DEFINITELY WANT
TO TELL YOU THAT I DO NOT
BELIEVE IT IS FAKE.
THESE WERE WORDS OF THE PAST AND
THESE THINGS DO NOT REPRESENT
ME.
>> Sean: I’M GLAD THE
CONGRESSWOMAN DELIVERED THAT
SPEECH.
BUT ULTIMATELY FOR DEMOCRATS,
THIS IS NOT AT ALL ABOUT
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE, THE NEW
CONGRESSWOMAN.
INSTEAD, IT’S A MERE POLITICAL
PLOY.
THEY WANT TO SMEAR ALL
CONSERVATIVES, ALL REPUBLICANS
AS EXTREME CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
SANCTIMONIOUS DEMOCRAT THAT
VOTED TODAY, THEY ARE ALL GUILTY
OF THE BIGGEST HOAX, THE BIGGEST
CONSPIRACY, THE LIES THAT THEY
HAVE TOLD FOR THREE STRAIGHT
YEARS.
THAT’S RIGHT, THE BIG TRUMP
RUSSIA COLLUSION LIE.
THEY HAVE PUT THIS COUNTRY
THROUGH --
FOR THREE YEARS AND EVERYTHING
THEY TOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WAS FALSE.
NOW WORKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BIG LIE, THEY HAVE THEIR ALLIES,
THEIR PRESS OFFICE.
WE REFERRED TO THEM AS THE MEDIA
MOB.
AND LISTENING TO THESE LYING
TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION TRUTHER’S
DULL MYS OF THE MARJORIE GREEN
TAYLOR SAGA, IT’S PRETTY
SICKENING.
SHE APOLOGIZED.
SHE SAID THAT HER BELIEFS WERE
WRONG, MISGUIDED.
MY QUESTION IS WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS GOING TO FOLLOW SUIT?
WHEN WILL THE MEDIA MOB CORRECT
SO MANY STORIES THEY ALL GOT
WRONG?
HERE IS MY PREDICTION.
DOWN THERE WILL FREEZE OVER
FIRST.
DON’T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
THEY ARE FEIGNING THEIR PONY
OUTRAGE AS USUAL AND PLAYACTING.
THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT STORY
OF OUR TIME.
IT’S NOT.
CONGRESSWOMAN GREEN, SHE HASN’T
SET THE AGENDA FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THE WAY THE RADICAL SQUAD LED BY
THE REAL SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
CONGRESSWOMAN O GARCIA CORTEZ
DOES FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
YOU PEOPLE KNOW CONGRESSWOMAN.
I DON’T KNOW A CONSERVATIVE OR A
REPUBLICAN THAT SUPPORTS OR
CONDONES THOSE PAST BELIEFS THAT
SHE DISAVOWED TODAY.
THE REAL STORY HERE IS THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOW OPENED THE
FLOODGATES WITH ALARMING NEW
PRECEDENT.
APPARENTLY VOTERS AT ELECTIONS,
THEY NO LONGER MATTER TO THEM.
ACCORDING TO THOSE WHO VOTED TO
REMOVE CONGRESSWOMAN GREENE FROM
COMMITTEES, A STANDARD THAT
DOESN’T BELIEVE DELL MIGHT APPLY
TO THEMSELVES, THOSE WHO VOTED
FOR HER BY A WHOPPING 70% OF THE
DON’T MATTER TO THE PEOPLE WHO
VOTED TODAY.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THEIR VOTES JUST DISCOUNTED.
LAWMAKERS OUTSIDE OF HER
DISTRICT, THEY ARE CALLING THE
SHOTS INCLUDING MANY TRULY
INSANE CONSPIRATORIAL DEMOCRATS,
THE ONES THAT HAVE NEVER
APOLOGIZED FOR THEIR PAST
RADICAL VIEWS, ANTI-SEMITIC
STATEMENTS, AND SO MUCH MORE.
WE’LL HAVE MORE IN A MOMENT.
NOW MEMBERS OF CONGRESS CANNOT
REPORTEDLYCAN REPORTEDLY BEPENAL
BELIEVED.
HOURS AGO, SHE ASKED THIS ALL
IMPORTANT QUESTION.
WHO’S NEXT QUESTION OR TAKE A
LOOK.
>> WHO’S NEXT?
WHO IS NEXT?
EVERYONE HAS SAID THINGS THEY
WISH THEY DIDN’T SAY.
EVERYONE HAS DONE THINGS THEY
WISH THEY DIDN’T DO.
SO WHO’S NEXT?
WHO WILL THEY CANCEL CULTURE
ATTACK NEXT QUESTION TODAY IT’S
MISS GREENE?
WHO IS A GOING TO BE TOMORROW?
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THE DEMOCRATS PEDDLED THE
BIGGEST CONSPIRACY THEORY OF ALL
TIME, THE RUSSIA HOAX.
>> Sean: COME TO THINK OF IT,
WHAT REPUBLICANS DO TAKE BACK
THE MAJORITY, THEY’VE GOT A
PRETTY GOOD SHOT FOR MY POSITION
IN 2022.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF
CONSPIRATORIAL DEMOCRATS.
THEY SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM
THEIR COMMITTEES, RIGHT?
APPLY STANDARDS EQUALLY.
EVERY DEMOCRAT THAT PUSHED THE
TRUMP RUSSIA CONSPIRACY THEORY,
THE LIES, THEY SHOULD ALL BE
STRIPPED OF THEIR COMMITTEES IF
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A ONE
STANDARD FITS ALL.
AND AS YOU POINTED OUT LAST
NIGHT, CONGRESSWOMAN O CASSIO
CORTEZ, SHE TOLD VOTERS THAT THE
WORLD WAS GOING TO END IN 12
YEARS.
CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR
TWEETING THAT EVIL IS REAL IS
HYPNOTIZING THE WORLD.
SPEAKER PELOSI, ADAM SCHIFF,
MAXINE WATERS, DOZENS OF OTHERS,
THEY ALL PUSH THE RUSSIA LIES
AND THE OPENLY SPECULATED THE
2016 ELECTION WAS RIGGED OR
STOLEN.
IGNORING HILLARY’S DOSSIER AND
IGNORING WHAT WE NOW KNOW ON THE
RECORD ABOUT CHRISTOPHER STEELE
AND THE SOURCE AND THAT THIS WAS
ALL RUSSIA DISINFORMATION THAT
HILLARY PAID FOR.
NEVER WANTED TO COMMENT ON THE
TRUTH.
THEY SAID THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WAS PUTIN’S
PUPPET.
PRETTY CRAZY STUFF FORGETTING OF
COURSE THAT HE SAID VLADIMIR I
WILL HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY AFTER
THE ELECTION.
IT DOESN’T EVEN TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THEIR VIOLENT INCITING X
ELECTIONINSURRECTIONIST LANGUAGE
MARK MY WORDS, TODAY’S POLITICAL
STUNT, IT WILL BACKFIRE FOR
DEMOCRATS IN KEEPING WITH THEIR
WHILE THIS ACTION DOES
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOTHING MORE THAN YET
ANOTHER POLITICAL PLOY.
BY THE WAY, DON’T ASK THEM TO
SAY THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
WHY?
BECAUSE AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
COMMITTEE MEETINGS, JERRY NADLER
SAID THAT WOULD NOT BE NECESSARY
IN HIS COMMITTEE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IN THE SPIRIT OF NATIONAL
UNITY AND NATIONAL PRIDE, WHICH
I KNOW WE ALL ASPIRE TO A
GREATER EXTENT AT THE BEGINNING
OF EACH MEETING, THE CHAIR OR
ONE OF THE DESIGNEES OF THE
CHAIR WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEAD US IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE.
WE ARE ALL AWARE THAT IN THESE
TIMES, IT’S IMPORTANT FOR THE
COUNTRY TO SEE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WORKING TOGETHER ON
SOME THINGS AND I RECOGNIZE
MYSELF TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE AMENDMENT.
IT IS UNNECESSARY.
THE HOUSE BEGINS EVERY DAY WITH
THE HOUSE OF THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE.
WE ARE COVERED BY THAT.
THERE IS NO NECESSITY TO SAY IT